le maire de guyancourt est inquiet dans
le cadre de la loi de finances 2012 mis
en place par l'ancien gouvernement
le fonds de solidarité de la région
ile-de-france a été modifié certaines
communes exonérés de prélèvements sur la
base de critères sociaux ne le sont
désormais plus c'est le cas des
guyancourt poissy nanterre ou encore
saint-ouen en tout huit maires d'île de
france se sont associés dans une lettre
commune au gouvernement objectif
proposer des amendements à la loi de
finances 2013 en préparation nous ne
sommes pas contre la solidarité mais
nous sommes pour le fait qu'elle soit
juste ce qu'il n'est pas bon c'est de
ponctionner à hauteur de 1 million 8 une
commune comme guillon cours
c'est brutal et c'est inéquitable c'est
trois fois le budget consacré aux
actions sociales pour les habitants de
la ville on ne peut pas donc prendre sur
le budget de la ville pour donner
ailleurs et ne pas laisser ce qui permet
à la commune de guyancourt d'agir
vis-à-vis de ses administrés auparavant
les critères sociaux des villes étaient
prises en compte dans le calcul des
prélèvements avec 50 % de logements
sociaux et un revenu moyen par habitant
relativement faible puis en cours en
étaient exonérés
le collectif propose de rétablir ce
dispositif le moment de les quitter
par exemple que des communes qui ont des
ressources et une population aisée ne
soit pas plafonnés protéger comme elles
le sont quand des communes comme les
nôtres lui en cours qui ont des charges
vis-à-vis de la population
elles ne sont pas plafonnés et protégé
ça ça serait la première
des mesures et puis la deuxième c'est
d'urgence de rétablir des critères
sociaux prendre en compte les
populations concernées avant de définir
le montant des contributions le
troisième amendement proposé par les
huit maires est une augmentation
progressive des prélèvements en fonction
du budget de fonctionnement de la ville
aujourd'hui ces prélèvements sont
plafonnés à 10 %
le projet de loi de finances 2013 est en
cours d'examen au parlement